But Mpemba was not the first person to observe this effect.
It dates back at least to Aristotle who noted...
..."The fact that the water has previously been warmed contributes to its freezing quickly:...
...for so it cools sooner.
Hence many people, when they want to cool hot water quickly, begin by putting it in the sun."
Sir Francis Bacon wrote "Tepid water will freeze more easily than water which is altogether cold."
...and Descartes in his essay on meteorology states...
..."We can also see by experiment that water which has been kept hot for a long time...
...freezes faster than any other sort, because those of its parts...
...which can least cease to bend evaporate while it is being heated."
So the observation that hot water freezes faster has a long and illustrious history.